hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde wir machen heute eine
werbe er chris sprachen lernen da die
das hier ist die erste situation wir
haben uns war bot jura der lifetime
subscription netflix oder häfen
unlimited giftcard tus dabei
jeder der da netflix nimmt hat einfach
keinen plan vom leben da also im ersten
moment habe ich mir jetzt gerade erst
mal gedacht hey netflix gucke ich fast
jeden tag aber bei starbucks bin ich
vielleicht einmal in der woche
allerdings es hat ja scheißegal wenn wir
nicht so eine giftcard hätte kannst du
auch bei starbucks einfach wasser holen
und irgendwie ein sandwich oder ein
salat oder
starbucks hat keinen salat oder auf
jeden fall würde ich mich als safe für
diese unlimited gift karte starbucks
entscheiden weil dann einfach nie wieder
sich was zu essen und zu trinken kaufen
muss also ist eigentlich relativ logisch
wenn man mal ein bisschen drüber
nachdenkt eine sache nummer 2 seht ihr
hier schon mutiger be able to run as
fast as the cheetah oder be able to fly
bartoli es fest
[Musik]
fliegen safe liegen egal wie langsam
alter wie geil wäre es wenn man einfach
fliegen könnte also ich glaube das ist
auch ziemlich eindeutig vor allem wenn
du in der stadt bis zum stemmer vor du
bist so extrem schnell und läufst du
schneller als die ganzen autos kann
deswegen wochen lust sich aber irgendwo
halt auch saugefährlich sondern man
vielen könnte wäre schon geil am nächste
sache motorrad das safe und pfeffer oder
heftes dem haircut haarschnitt
hundertprozentig als ich sie so fresh
aus gerade mal kurz überlegen
martha gerechnet
also hier würde ich auf jeden fall den
gleichen haarschnitt für mein leben lang
auswählen weil handy alter gerade bei
den ganzen technik produkten so da kommt
jedes jahr irgendwie was neues raus
womit man dann mehr optionen wieder hat
mehr möglichkeiten allerdings das
nächste level etwa oder reste liegen
würde ich gegen gar nichts resselberger
allerdings muss ich mich ja hier
entscheiden und wenn ich mich
entscheiden müsste zwischen einem kampf
mit einem bären und dem kampf mit einem
alligator würde ich glaube ich den bären
nehmen weil ich doch dann würde ich
einfach mit dem kuscheln
frage nummer fünf meine lieben freunde
what you'll never stop the growing
dollar oder never need to sleep
das verstehe ich gerade gar nicht mehr
wann me to sleep das ist ja nicht also
man muss nie schlafen man es immer fit
man muss nicht irgendwie seinen körper
wieder aufbauen dadurch dass man
irgendwie schläft und energie tankt aber
never stop crying dollar
na das ist ja scheiße du hast nie auf
größer zu werden so ich würde lieber
wirklich überhaupt nicht schlafen müssen
oder checke ich das gerade irgendwie
überhaupt nicht ihr könnt ihr übrigens
mal gern zu jeder einzelnen frage hier
eure meinung und in die kommentare
schreiben würde mich mega interessieren
wofür ihr euch entscheiden würde
allerdings machen wir weiter mit der
sechsten trage waterloo soul of dutys
oder lose all of your hair haare
safe hundertprozentig die haare schnitt
guckt euch beispielsweise train the rock
johnson an der hat ja auch ne glatze und
dadurch dass er halt so ein krankes
geiles lächeln hat unsere heftige muskel
ist er trotzdem sexiest man alive
gewonnen das wäre dann auch ich könnt
ihr euch mich mit glatze vorstellen
alltag der menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abgestoßen als bei der frage
hier nämlich auch hundertprozentig lose
all of your hair
bisher war ich nur bei dem kampf mit dem
bären und alligator mir ein bisschen
unsicher sonst hatte ich mal 100 prozent
des tisches mit you'll never be able to
leave your house oder only being the
house verpfeifen benutzt er detail das
ist schwer
entweder du darfst sein haus nie wieder
verlassen oder du das immer nur für fünf
minuten in deinem auge nein ich glaube
aber ich würde das mit den fünf minuten
nehmen allerdings ist diese frage hat
auch extrem schwierig so viel lieber die
ganze zeit in einem haus zu sein ist
scheiße du siehst nichts von der welt
wenn du mal was mit freunden machen
willst kannst nicht irgendwie ins kino
gehen oder zum döner laden den man oder
keine ahnung was sondern muss zu hause
sein muss zu hause bleiben allerdings
auf der anderen seite darf man nur fünf
minuten nach hause
aber wenn ich darüber nachdenke würdig
schon die fünf minuten dem glauberg for
you hate that make money oder word
phobos that you love but may kleffmann
ich mache lieber viel geld doch egal ob
ich denn den chef mag oder nicht mal
klar es ist nicht egal aber wenn ich
mich jetzt entscheiden müssen zwischen
der menge geld und keiner menge geld
also ein ganz bisschen geld aber dafür
mag ich meinen boss oder ich mag mein
boss halt nicht nur die safety nehmen
safe hunderttausend prozent also ein
paar entscheidungen in diesem heutigen
video fallen mir extrem leicht
allerdings andere wiederum sind extrem
schwierig machen wir mal weiter mit dem
nächsten hiroshi kawano oldies secrets
of space oder nordic secrets auf die
außen space
klar space hundertprozentig gar keine
frage oceana was interessiert mich sagen
ozean klar wenn da und jetzt riesige
tiere sind würde ich das natürlich auch
gern wissen aber wenn ich mich
entscheiden müsste safe safe weltall
stelle mir vor ihr wüsstet irgendwo gibt
es einen anderen planeten alter da
laufen pizzas rum alter da will ich ja
gar nicht mehr klarkommen frage nummer
10 von 17 da sind wir mittlerweile schon
angekommen freunde schauen wir mal was
wir hier haben ist oder exchange beides
ziemlich egal ich meine man weiß ja
immer schon welche zeit gerade genau ist
wenn ich einfach auf mein handy gucke 16
46 so guckt halt drauf so hab ich das
jetzt direkt auf dem kopf oder wenn ich
kurz auf mein handy oder auf meine
herkunft egal
deswegen war der zehnte frage hätte ich
auf jeden fall das rechte genommen auch
bisher wie exakt immer und auf change
would you gotta be in unknown super hero
oder wie auch taylors villa ich glaube
das heißt böse mich nicht ich weiß aber
nicht ob ich richtig ausgesprochen habe
also ich glaube ich wäre ja weil ich
halt einfach ein herzensguter mensch bin
das letzte euro-land an
aber ich kann nicht also selbst wenn da
irgendwie eine spinne bei mir und ich
hasse spinnen dann packt ihn glas und
packt die nach draußen oder bin ich ja
auch quasi also ich würde hier an der
stelle auch auf jeden fall nehmen wie in
anderen superhero als anderen anstatt
der stelle
frage nummer zwölf freunde von 17 jetzt
kommen wir zu den letzten fünf sechs
fragen wo james moll rock indie hot
shoes oder us häfen martin j
[Musik]
ich hab immer einen kleinen stein was
unnormal ab oder man hat immer schlamm
in seinen schuhen okay das ist das ist
jetzt bisschen also seid beide shows hab
ich glaube ich würde dich ich weiß nicht
was ich nehmen würde
ich weiß es wirklich nicht der stein
facto normal ab mit der zeit weil er
halt einfach weh tut und schlamm ist
halt einfach ekelhaft aber ich glaube
ich wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste
will ich den stein nehmen allerdings ist
die nächste frage what you are sabir
brilliance scientist und ein foto von
arbeit einstellen oder bio world famous
ich glaube ich werde ende juni betrieb
sich kamera bist kannst du deine kunst
halt für unnormal viel geld verkaufen
verdienst nun einmal viel geld bei mir
geht's um geld wäre aber das ist halt
das worüber man nachdenken muss und sein
team sei da hätte ich glaube ich nicht
so viel von was mein leben an mir frage
nummer 14 motorrad chocolate as you are
forever oder we are one million dollars
geld
schokolade ist scheiße für dich der zum
100 100 1000 prozentig eine millionen
dollar allerdings muss ich auch sagen
dass es bei mir zumindest so ist dass
die schokolade gar nicht mal so gerne
esse ich bin immer mehr der salzige typ
also wenn der chip stehen oder
schokoladig entscheid mich immer für die
chips immer die ganze zeit allerdings
kommen nun schon 215 frage und zwar der
drittletzten frage für das heutige video
damit werde forget to speak oder what's
up dad autorität
safe reden ist so wichtig alter es ist
so wichtig und so wichtig echt
unangenehm wie oft ich mich im heutigen
video versprechen dort hat mit ihnen
lesen wäre es halt so dass ich immer
irgendwie freunde fragen könnte york
kann es mir doch mal kurz vorlesen oder
siri kann der auch teilweise nachrichten
vorlesen das mache ich relativ häufig
wenn ich lange nachrichten bekommen also
ich würde auf jeden fall forget auto
mitnehmen allerdings ist hier schon
nächste frage what have ye li oslo
internet oder avril i bet von sydney
okay das ist auch wieder total easy weil
ich weiß nicht wann das video des ok ist
es von 2009 10 aber man kann ja auch mit
dem internet telefonieren
also ich brauche telefon signal always
thought i bet von sage ich und die
letzte frage fürs heutige video ist
would rather be able to change von
singing your past oder the thing we get
out of sale klar die frage ist heftig
ehrlich gesagt würde ich aber gar nichts
ändern wollen wir mal im leben
ich bin eigentlich relativ zufrieden und
die person die ich jetzt gerade bin bin
ich halt nur geworden aufgrund der
aktionen die ich halt was kannst du
eigentlich also ich würde mich hier bei
der letzten frage auch hundertprozentig
für die real existierende geld auch noch
geld entscheiden weil wenn ich
irgendwann mal scheiße bauen sollte und
ich irgendwie ins gefängnis gehen müsste
was natürlich die hoffen wäre dann hätte
ich keine karten könnt sagen hey an der
stelle mich dass heute geht jetzt alles
auch beenden meine lieben freunde sorry
dass das heutige video einfach nur so
ein kurzes weather testing war
allerdings habe ich heute enorm viel
stress wir haben mega viel heute mit dem
podcast zeit verbracht sander und ich
haben extrem viel geplant auch für
eventuellen meine podcast oder so die
wir machen beide male kamen gestern neue
podcast raußen link dazu
selbstverständlich und in der
beschreibung falls die folge noch nicht
gehört hat ist wieder sehr lustig
geworden allerdings mit ihm freuen wenn
ich das heute wieder gefahren da bin ich
mich sehr darüber einen daumen hoch von
euch unter dem video hier freuen
schreibt mir gerne und in die kommentare
wie ihr euch bei bestimmten fragen hier
entschieden hätte doch eventuell ganz
anders gedacht hätte als ich ganz anders
kombiniert und euch ganz anders
irgendwie ja dementsprechend halt für
eine andere sache entschieden hätten
keinen kanal falls kein teil der lupo
seit und jetzt kommt auch das auto nicht
lasst euch endlich jetzt in ruhe
[Musik]
nie